One of my first reactions was pure terror that
because I was so excited I just became paranoid
that I was going to um somehow blurt out that
I refuse the Fields medal when obviously I
wanted to accept it. So I think I had the most
bizarre response to his question that I very very
slowly and deliberately said, yes I accept the
Fields medal which is the most surreal phrase.
So certainly when I was in secondary school I
was aware of the concept of the Fields medal
as a sort of maths version of the Nobel prize
or something. I think the Fields model was the
only maths prize I was aware of then. I can't
remember at all when the first time I'd heard
about the Fields medal would be but yeah it must
have been at some point when I was at school.
(Brady: Not Goodwill Hunting? That that's when I first heard of
it. Goodwill Hunting made the Fields medal famous)
- Following you around going 'the Fields medal, the Fields medal'
- It's about my medal isn't it? Oh God I can
go home and get it for you, you can have it.
- Yeah soit took me an embarrassingly long period of time
to watch Goodwill Hunting I think. So um despite
the fact I've been keen on maths for such a long
time yeah somehow everyone else seemed to have
watched Goodwill Hunting but I hadn't watched it
so I didn't learn about it from there.
- (So it's welldocumented, we've even spoke about it. You started)
(having some successes and making some impressive
breakthroughs; and people started talking about)
(you being a contender for the Fields medal. I
used to see on Reddit every time Fields medal)
(season came around your name would be amongst the
possible winners. Did people ever talk to you about)
(it? Were people- did people ever say to you,
'James I reckon you could win it this year', like)
(things like that. Were you very aware of it?)
- Somaybe a couple of colleagues heard loose comments
uh and so you made indications that they thought
it was possible. But um strangely the biggest thing
was that people didn't talk about it. That normally
mathematicians like to gossip a little bit about
Fields medals and things um and so in some cycles
sort of when we're just having uh dinner or if
we're having coffee or something together people
gossip about who might win a Fields medal. But it
was notable that for this cycle no one was talking
to me about the Fields medal at all and I seemed
to be cut out of all the normal gossiping that
was going on. So in terms of my interactions
with colleagues it was actually more than not
talking to me than them talking to me that uh
was an indication that they thought maybe I was
one of the candidates.
- (How did you find out?)
So I was decorating my house, so I was at the top ofa
ladder painting one of the ceilings and I came
down to have a break and I checked my phone and
then I had an email from the IMU president saying
'could we arrange a zoom call sometime soon'. And
I had a suspicion then as to what it was. I was
desperately trying to convince myself that
he wanted me to be on some boring committee
and this was nothing to get excited about at all
because I didn't want to get ahead of myself.
But realistically that's when I had the first sort
of inclination that maybe I'd won the Fields medal
and then we organised this Zoom call in my office.
And fortunately he was very kind and just said
basically straight up, oh we've decided to award
you the Fields medal. So it cut all the tension
out pretty quickly.
- (What was your first feeling?Do you remember what first went through your head?)
Um obviously I was ecstatic. The IMU president asks
you um will you accept the Fields medal - because I
guess there was this notable case with Perelman
that he declined the Fields medal. So in fact
one of my first reactions was pure terror that
because I was so excited I just became paranoid
that I was going to somehow blurt out that
I refuse the Fields medal when obviously
I wanted to accept it. So I think I had the most
bizarre response to his question that I very very
slowly and deliberately said 'yes I accept the
Fields medal' which is the most surreal phrase
um that I think I said because I was just
completely terrified that somehow I'd been
awarded the Fields medal and I would
accidentally reject the Fields medal.
(Okay - well done for not rejecting it! What's
the chat like then? Does he tell you- obviously)
(he tells you some procedural things; are you
sworn to secrecy? What's the deal at this point?)
Um yeah they give you- um he said that he'd talk
me through a few of the basic procedural things
and then there's a number of extra details
that go through. They strongly ask you
to keep it secret- they understand
that you'll tell a couple of very close
um family members and maybe a couple of close
colleagues um but uh they're very very keen to
keep it as secret as possible because naturally
that's part of the um fun of all of these awards.
(The Fields medal- there's obviously other people who win
the Fields medal; do they tell you the other)
(winners at that point? Or do you not know who
your sort of colleagues are at that stage?)
No so I only knew for sure who the other winners
were when I walked into the backstage room in
Helsinki right before the Fields medal ceremony. I
was certainly trying to sort of guess from other
things and you talk to some journalists. So
I think I had heard from one of the journalists
that I was the youngest Fields medalist because
the journalists obviously know the other ones.
But yeah I only knew for sure who the other
ones were when I was backstage and I recognised
the other people.
- (So when you got off that callwho did you tell?)
- Funnily enough this was in the
early evening and I'd arranged to meet a group of
mathematicians in the pub. And so I went straight
off to the pub because I was already a bit late to
meet them but I had to keep myself very quiet and
not tell anyone. So I had this very awkward period
of like socialising with some other mathematicians
and just having chats about different things-
- (Sothey're like 'why are you late James?' And you're)
(like 'oh sorry, I was just winning a Fieldsmedal')
- Yeah so I made up some rubbish excuse
about like getting distracted and getting
too into my maths and something running over
um and I was desperately trying to sort of not
have a big beaming smile the entire time and to
just talk about other things. So the Fields medal
is always normally given at the International
Congress of Mathematicians. This was uh due to
be held in Russia um in Saint Petersburg but
because of the war in Ukraine it was decided
that this was not feasible for obvious reasons
and so there was a somewhat last minute switch to
Helsinki. And most of the International Congress
was then held online but they had an in-person
ceremony for the awarding of the Fields medals
in Helsinki along with the initial talks and
the opening ceremony.
- (You go backstage - what, to some)
(green room or something - and that's when you
first see the other winners?)
- Yeah that's right.
Um uh yeah so I'm there in my suit feeling
super nervous and I go backstage and there's
all the other winners and um I think everyone is
sort of super nervous and being a bit quiet and
then uh Hugo Dominil-Copin comes in and he's
exceptionally lively and he starts chatting
to people and he breaks the ice and then
suddenly everyone's chatting to everyone
else and I think that was great because it
calmed my nerves an awful lot.
- (Did you know the)
(three others? Like to recognise them or?)
- Um Ivisually recognised them yeah. So I had maybe
seen one or two of them before in person but
I basically hadn't seen them in person and I
didn't know them personally but I knew who they
were and I recognised them from photos I'd seen.
(Did you know any much about their mathematics?)
- Um Iknew a little bit about uh most of their mathematics
yeah. I'd heard about some of the sort of main
results that they'd had.
- (I sometimes look at)
(these lists of four yearly winners as these
clusters and I always think you're kind of- you're)
(you're all bonded now aren't you? Like that you're-
you're a little class. Do you feel a bond with them?)
Um I certainly feel a bit of a bond with them,
yeah. I mean it's not like we've had any uh extra
community - it's not- we don't have a 2022 Fields
medalists WhatsApp group or anything like that.
But uh yeah there's a certain
amount of camaraderie that uh you know
it was a very important time in my life and they
were all going through exactly the same thing at
exactly the same time.
- (Brilliant. And what happens
at the ceremony? Did you have to make a speech? Do)
(you just take your medal and walk off the stage?
How does the procedure go?)
- So there's the award
ceremony initially where I just take my medal. Then
there's another distinguished mathematician in the
area who gives a sort of presentation on each of
the winner's works but that's all I have to do for
um that first day. And then in the second day I
give a lecture associated to winning the Fields
medal.
- (So then you've got it, you know, you bring
it home - we'll look at it in a minute hopefully.)
(There it is, I can't wait to see it. But um like
what next? Like it's kind of like- I know there)
(are some other big prizes in mathematics now,
like big big prizes but the Fields medal still)
(seems to be like the Nobel prize-y one. Is there
is there a feeling at all of 'hmm now what? Like)
(that's like- that this could be the biggest thing
I ever win!)
- Yeah it's only downhill from here.
Um I mean I think most mathematicians are
kind of really motivated by mathematics. And so
um I'm completely ecstatic and overjoyed that I've
won the Fields medal uh but you know the thing
that's always driven me is understanding kind of
truth in mathematics and getting to the heart of
um kind of mathematical puzzles and things
like that. Um and the sort of real satisfaction
um is from when I prove a theorem that I really
like, I get this immense joy from that. And so
that's still what drives me on and that's what
drove me initially and that hasn't changed at
all. So um I hope that I can keep my feet on
the ground and not get too full of myself or
anything like that, and to just continue being a
research mathematician who's driven by trying to
understand research mathematics. Yeah so the
Fields medal is only awarded once every four
years and it's only awarded to mathematicians
who are under the age of 40. So it's very much
only given to young mathematicians. I think
originally this was intended to be a
prize for promising young mathematicians as an
encouragement but just for historical reasons
the people who've won it has led to becoming a
much more prestigious award than maybe it was
ever originally intended to be. And so there's now
this odd status that one- at least one of the very
premier prizes in mathematics has this very
young age limit. Yeah I feel that there's
obvious benefits and disadvantages that um on
some level I sometimes find it a little bit
dissatisfying that Nobel prizes
are given to people really right
at the end of their career; often they've
been retired for a long period of time
and so it's not selecting the sort of most
exciting work and the people who you're expecting
to come up with the next breakthroughs. And that's
one nice thing about the Fields medal, that it is
choosing very promising and talented young
mathematicians um and people who are therefore
maybe amongst the people who might be making the
next set of breakthroughs.
- (You can- and you can)
(use the benefit of it - some of those little doors
it opens and advantages it gives you, you can use)
(while you're still practicing.)
- Uh yeah exactly.
So that's certainly one benefit of the Fields
medal. Obviously a big disadvantage is that the
relatively low age limit has a certain distorting
effect that different education systems accelerate
people to different extents and so a 40 year
cutoff is quite arbitrary. People who have to
do military service are at disadvantages; people
who maybe take career breaks because of caring
responsibilities or having children or things like
that it sort of slightly unfairly disadvantages.
The fact that it's just once every four years with
this age limit means that uh what year you're born
mod 4 has a advantage as to whether you have more
possible research time to make contributions or
not. So it has lots of sort of slightly undesirable
effects like this as well.
- (Yeah if you solve the
Riemann hypothesis as a 41 year old - too bad)
Yeah exactly but if you'd somehow just been born one
year earlier then everything would have been fine.
(Can I please see the medal?)
- You can indeed. So thisis my medal.
- (It comes in that case does it?)
Yeah it came in this case.
- (What was it like when they
handed it to you? Was it- what did that feel like?)
Um I mean I think I was in a daze the
entire time uh through the ceremony so
um everything felt amazing and I was just on
cloud nine but I was also slightly unaware of
everything that was going on.
- (Did any of yourfamily come over to Helsinki?)
- No, so the
strange thing was that um I was awarded my medal
on the 5th of July but my first son was going to
be born on the 7th of July. So um I received the
medal on the 5th; on the morning of the 6th I gave
my talk associated to the Fields medal. Normally
they give the talks in alphabetical order but
they changed the order because I needed to get
back to the UK from Finland. And I flew straight
back to the UK after giving the first talk in
the morning um and then in the morning of the
7th of July my first son was born. So that was a-
it's going to be difficult to top that week.
(Yeah, brilliant. And the last question I have is what
do you do with it? Like where like- what do you)
(do with the medal? Do you ever look at it? Does it
have pride of place? Is it locked in a safe or)
(like- you know as much as you can tell us.)
- Yeah sothis is one of the slightly disappointing things
I guess that because it is sort of valuable,
both sentimentally but also I think the medal
itself is gold and so has some value, I
sort of have it locked in a box at home which
means I don't actually see it very often, it's
just sort of locked in a cupboard somewhere.
And so in some ways it's a bit silly that
I win this medal that I'm super proud of,
I really like, but rather than show it off or
look at it it just gets put in the cupboard.
A longer version of this interview can be found
on our Numberphile2 channel and I've also turned
that extended version into an episode of the
numberphile podcast. You'll find that in all the
usual podcast places. Plus for more videos with
James Maynard and an assortment of other Fields
medalists check out links in the video description.
This episode was supported by Brilliant,
makers of fantastic online courses and puzzles and
quizzes like the ones you're looking at right now.
Now no doubt these are a workout for your brain,
covering all manner of mathematics, computer
science, and just science in general but it's
not just telling you stuff - talking down to you.
These are courses that you interact with and
one of my favourite things about Brilliant is
sometimes it's funny, it has personality. It's made
by people with smiles on their faces, you can tell.
This is just fantastic stuff, it's so much fun.
And now Brilliant has a 30-day free trial so
there's another reason to go and have a look. Go to
brilliant.org/numberphile for the trial but that
code's also going to get you 20% off their annual
plan. Check them out people; it's clever, it's quirky.
'Hello?' And the voice was saying 'Hello, this
is László Lovász from Budapest'. And then my
heart skipped a beat.
See whether you're living in
an even dimensional space or odd dimensional space-